[Musica]
fino a qualche anno fa quando mi
svegliavo la prima cosa che facevo era
quella di allungare un braccio sul
comodino e con un occhio aperto e un
occhio chiuso
prendevo lo smartphone volevo leggere le
notifiche con un misto di ansia e
desiderio e per scoprire chi mi aveva
cercato durante la notte e quindi non
solo le notifiche guardavo ma aprivo
whatsapp e guardavo tutte le satta e poi
a primo facebook e guardavo tutto il
field e apriva le e mail e che fai non
rispondi in tutto questo erano già
trascorsi venti minuti e io sempre con
occhio aperto un occhio chiuso stavo nel
mio letto e l'ora era tarda quindi non
avevo più tempo di fare colazione e
prendeva un caffè di corsa e subito e
andavo al lavoro sì perché io mi occupo
di marketing e comunicazione digitale e
quindi andavo in giro per clienti per
parlare di digitale e fino a quel
momento io ero come dire pieno di
digitale consideriamo che controllava
l'email ogni cinque minuti
anzi tre per una mia tacita regola
rispondevo subito perché sennò sembrava
brutto anzi mi faceva sentire anche più
produttivo pensate e questi social le
notifiche e tutto il resto inchiodava mi
sa che cosa ha una situazione dove io
non ero più produttivo
io non non ero più me stesso e questo fa
sì che anche le persone che giravano
intorno a me mi dicevano alessio stai
sempre con lo smartphone in mano e io
rispondevo ma io quello smartphone ci
lavoro è questa questa situazione andava
avanti andando avanti quindi il digitale
che per me è era ed è un lavoro stava
diventando anche un problema
fino a un certo punto della mia vita è
successa una cosa molto particolare
comparve l'insonnia non dormivo più alle
2 di notte aprire gli occhi e ovviamente
che cosa facevo con gli occhi spalancati
al soffitto prendevo lo smartphone
un'altra volta aprivo facebook
whatsapp le chat con l'illusione che
questo avrebbe agevolato il mio recupero
del sonno
tutt'altro veramente la mia vita andava
in una direzione che dovevo intervenire
cioè era diventato un punto di rottura
anzi dovevo cercare un equilibrio bene
siamo in una fase della piazza si chiama
era dell'informazione ma potremmo
chiamarla era della distrazione
ovviamente siamo sopra stimolati di
comunicazione di notifiche di tweet di
foto e questo ci questo innesca un
circolo di ricompense ecco pieni di
distrazione il punto è questo
noi non siamo più attenti non riusciamo
più a concentrarci e questo lo sappiamo
bene o meglio lo sanno bene chi progetta
le app o gli strumenti come lo
smartphone
il problema è che loro commercializzano
e quindi guadagnano sulla nostra
attenzione e se pensiamo all'interno di
una giornata a quanta disattenzione e
distrazione perdiamo beh basti pensare
che in una l'ultima ricerca si dice che
il 36 per cento del nostro tempo
lavorativo lo perdiamo dietro alle
distrazioni e questo è un dato molto
significativo se poi lo accostiamo al
mito del multitasking chi di voi non fa
più cose contemporaneamente nello stesso
tempo bene questo ovviamente
la facciamo passare come una grande
abilità invece tutt'altro gli studi ci
dicono che se abusato di questo
multitasking la produttività diminuisce
del 40 per cento
perché poi noi non siamo più concentrati
e questo fa sì che innesca un meccanismo
virtuoso che quale siamo distratti non
riusciamo a completare all'interno della
giornata il lavoro si accumula nel
weekend non stacchiamo e arriva piano
piano lo stress
ecco questa situazione diciamo che non è
proprio quella ottimale
quindi siamo veramente sotto forma sotto
una grande forma di hackeraggio di che
cosa della nostra attenzione ma della
nostra concentrazione ma soprattutto del
cervello
basti pensare che l'ultima ricerca ci
dice che il tempo medio di
concentrazione di un pesciolino rosso e
di 9 secondi noi 8 secondi ecco diciamo
che è questo dato è molto molto
importante e ci fa capire una dimensione
qual è la dimensione che per
concentrarci dobbiamo separarci dallo
smartphone solo separandosi quindi solo
rallentando riusciamo a comprendere le
potenzialità di questo grande strumento
e nella vita digitale
non dobbiamo andare più veloci
dobbiamo solo avere la capacità e
l'abilità di saper rallentare solo
rallentando riusciamo a portare benefici
nella nostra vita
innanzitutto il più grande beneficio è
che nella separazione con lo smartphone
riusciamo ad avere più energia
questo significa che ci alimentiamo di
energia ma soprattutto abbiamo una
capacità di salute mentale
inoltre abbiamo più focus che cosa
significa che nella separazione con lo
smartphone noi riusciamo a essere più
concentrati e riusciamo ad essere più
produttivi pensate che questa abilità
sarà l'abilità del 21 set xxi secolo
quello di essere concentrati e speed di
saper lavorare in modo focus infine ma
non per ultimo separandoci dallo
smartphone
abbiamo più tempo per chi per noi e per
le nostre relazioni interpersonali
voi vi starete domandando ma come
facciamo a separarsi dallo smartphone
e qui il vero nocciolo innanzitutto
dobbiamo immaginarci come degli atleti
l'atleta in questo caso il nuotatore
raggiunge la performance quando e focus
sugli obiettivi e prendi un momento di
distacco cioè il momento di distacco di
recupero ed è importante tanto quanto
l'allenamento che fa in acqua del resto
non può stare tutto il giorno nella
vasca notare e del resto noi non
possiamo stare tutto il giorno con lo
smartphone in mano come lui si allena
anche lui nella separazione dello
smartphone riusciamo ad allenare che
cosa la nostra mente la nostra
concentrazione ci sono alcuni momenti
della nostra vita che devono essere
svolti con una attenzione particolare
con attenzione proprio profonda e sono
momenti di vita ma sono anche momenti
lavorativi e quindi se pensiamo a quando
siamo in volo e mettiamo e cellulare in
modalità aereo
prendiamoci dei momenti all'interno
della giornata e mettiamoci in modalità
focus
solo così riusciremo a comprendere al
meglio il lavoro ma soprattutto a
svolgere al meglio i compiti della
giornata
stando sempre più esposti con la polis
con i social e quindi stando sempre
quello smartphone in mano
c'è il rischio che la contaminazione
delle nostre emozioni sia più evidente
che cosa significa che le nostre
emozioni
seguono la stregua di quello che è i
canali sociali e quindi in questo noi
non siamo più capaci o meglio non siamo
più bravi a saper riconoscere le nostre
emozioni e soprattutto i nostri pensieri
e allora abbiamo bisogno ha di
contrapporre al brusio e al rumore di
tutto quello che solo le registrazioni
le notifiche il silenzio il silenzio è
fondamentale perché il silenzio ci rende
capaci ma soprattutto il silenzio ci
comunica ecco per enfatizzare questa
frase questo concetto
prendo in prestito le parole di lucio on
line un famoso filosofo contemporaneo
dove lui dice che il medium dello
spirito e il silenzio che è stato
chiaramente distrutto dal digitale trovo
estremamente interessante questo punto
perché alla fine noi ce la stiamo
prendendo quello smartphone
il problema non è lo smartphone
il problema è la nostra relazione che
mettiamo in campo con lo smart phone lo
smartphone è più grande strumento
rivoluzionario che ci abbiamo si sia mai
capitato fino ad oggi è quindi solo
separandoci dallo smartphone riusciamo a
comprendere innanzitutto chi noi stessi
riusciamo a comprendere qual è il tempo
e qual è l'attenzione che vogliamo
relegare impostare con lo smartphone
perché alla fine alla velocità del
digitale
noi dobbiamo accostare la profondità
dell'uomo perché in fondo la vita e
tutto quello
che che noi facciamo è che va oltre
lasciare un semplice mi piace su
facebook grazie
[Musica]